hello welcome to this video so bad shoe
and so bahu iana we gotta Trump boys
playing that line okay say going for a 4
Wow kind of line is that never seen this
one okay but see five is too logical
move yeah and it must be okay it's what
i'm trying to say wow you go f3 and then
you take on f6 amazing killing your dark
squares completely okay so let's
concentrate losing this one would be
pretty awful basically wide was this
terrible players if you want yeah upped
up the ante in a way like if you don't
win now you feel bad so let's focus why
is this bad he's given up his dark
squared Bishop yeah and then hit f3
played and gives up his dark squared
Bishop completely ruining his dark
squares this is some simply
strategically very very bad so let's see
how to exploit it can go is 6i can go
deform I can take only 3 a couple of
options hmm
maybe de for it well I have to be I
should be as play quickly because this
is the main danger of this kind of
position you think that you're and you
should be a much better and rightly so
but then you try to exploit it to the
fullest and invest much time and then at
the end you you lack the necessary time
to to win the game which happens to me
so so often ok so what to do now and I'm
a porn down him and I'm already pretty
sure that I didn't didn't play it well
but I have to work with this now
mmm you probably have to take it I guess
so some b6 move is going Bishop a 60
whom
can go Bishop a four to five and here we
try that
and so here probably check check and
then what can also go here is going to
go 95 I guess then I've got to eat six
probably here 95 rookie eight and then e
60 men pretty remarkable
yeah why doesn't he play 95 nobody
understands that you're rather wants to
put it on the edge of the board what
does he want to do see
probably run into some silly checkmater
so that would be the fitting way to end
this game okay so Bishop c3 is that
ships III look b3 rooty to check King
III and doesn't look right but you're
threatening see for him
mc3 ruby three check King III I don't
have a move there and believe all that
stuff looks like that time morning I
cannot prevent c4e area amazing check
check
not quite sure about this maybe I'm
still kind of okay with this not only
for but I don't know there was a very
strange game or is a very strange game
what is a bit a bit early check check
I would love to win that game i already
wore them and they've got some chances
to do that check
I know just promoting here what what
what the what the beep are you doing
check
white resigns okay so i don't have to
feel that bad i mean have to feel bad
for not just winning out of the opening
but at least I am won the game somehow
yeah you know it is just absolutely
terrible to take here strategically
speaking you cannot give her the dark
squared Bishop with this kind of
structure it's just that just awful but
i didn't i didn't exploit it and this is
the this is the the sad truth even
though i'm playing the engine moves and
this is also given by the engine but
defaults not the engine just says I
should take with a very clear advantage
jen has some logic yeah why do I give up
the pawn down this is this is what them
compass given that it's probably yeah
that's a somewhat better version of the
game I mean I will get that porn simply
and note that the dark squares yeah
cannot cancel and gas is much better for
black but the way it went I mean I was a
pawn down and that wasn't that wasn't
good no not good at all and check if he
would have done I think if you would
have played yeah he I mean night a for
it's just like who I mean this is the
most natural move ever why not put it in
the middle of the board and I'm just in
bad shape yeah this I don't know it's
just pretty pretty terrible
yeah a shame that I like one's got into
this into the straw and this is this is
the the best thing that I cannot play
Bishop see three year it's absolutely
not working can check the end after King
III amount of moves losing the piece so
he gets in c form check check Carol
performs mysterious chess here i'm back
into the game i mean this is kind of
ridiculous chang here no root be three
steady took and no jack yeah yeah I'm
just completely winning check chan
garrison at the end I got the win that
turn the opening yeah play deserved in a
way but I just played a terrible game
right after that giving him giving him
far too much them and then I've got
lucky that he misplaced his pieces and
such a weird way oh ok thanks for
watching